I I need to re-meet you guys like hello
reintroduce myself I'm I'm Esther who
are you are you identifying as a male or
female what are your foot your outfit is
just shot I don't know why well I know
you're genderless now you're gen Z
I'm not even looking like wait a second
from her shoulders I expect it from
thank you you're coming to femininity
and New York took it away you both are
wearing the same pants and we're all
wearing New Balances we've all become
gender neutral we're our gender neutral
because honestly boys do wear this
outfit they really do though
Julie is an FDA approved morning after
pill that helps stop pregnancy before it
starts go to juliecare.co to learn more
or find Julie at your nearest CVS Target
or Walmart today that's
juliecare.co to learn more this show is
sponsored by betterhelp find more
balance with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com trash Tuesday
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code trash Tuesday at manscape.com
manscaped is grooming from face to waste
for men and the stuff that hangs a
little lower
you can get 20 off and free shipping
with the code trash Tuesday at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
trash Tuesday make this followers day
one he won't forget with manscaped and
he won't forget when you get your dad
ball trimmers
hey sluggies happy Tuesday I am on the
road you can come see me in San Antonio
on June 23rd and 24th at the LOL Comedy
Club I also will be in Philadelphia in
August at the punchline and you can see
me in Austin Texas at the Vulcan gas
company October 6th through 7th I also
have dates in San Francisco San Jose and
a lot of really cool places so go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me every Thursday
at 12 p.m PST on YouTube on anniewood
with me and Todd come check it out hi
slugs I am so happy and excited to be
back on the road sharing my crazy stand
up with all of you
um we're gonna have so much fun at these
shows I will be in New York City July
19th through 22nd I will be in DC
September 28th and Boston at the Wilbur
September 30th and more get tickets at
astronice.com I cannot wait to have fun
with you guys this summer and this fall
[Music]
thank you
I want to talk about our new balances we
did not plan this we've morphed into
each other without each other first of
all this is all of you becoming me
because I've been wearing these shoes
since my 18th birthday when my dad got
me running shoes it's so funny that
yours are the ones with like doodoo on
the bottom yeah I hate to tell you but
there's
foreign
[Laughter]
thank you guys for the excuse me where
is Bobby's photo behind me we're done we
can't we're done oh we're done no save
it for tigerbelly [__] we're done no no
Bobby no Carlos we talk about none of
these people wait your your necklace
became an earring wait okay since I know
that you still talked to Bobby or I'm
assuming that and he's on tour talk to
people imagine she didn't talk to Bobby
please warn him what are these what's
the little bralette thing happening here
they're very pushed up I got back so I
was in New York for two months and this
morning I wake up I'm like back in La
like get gonna get up early live my life
both cars not working so you need to
tell Bobby that someone needs probably
you I do that run his engine yeah I do
that okay just Twinkie I just want to
let you know Bobby would never think of
you and that's
be careful about your pipes at home you
have to run your water run your showers
or else it gets a really bad smell if
you don't run your plumbing for two
months do you not know that
that I had covered it was okay so I
didn't have covered Esther knows her
smells
husband knows about house smells I knew
that one um but the water was brown but
it's kind of always Brown um anyway oh
but after your baths yeah
because it starts Brown and gets Browner
the cars would not start this morning
and I was like this is because okay I
don't know if you guys bring everyone up
to speed I've been in New York for two
months I full-blown became a New Yorker
we can tell by your nails
[Laughter]
oh yes those very realistic Paparazzi
I've never seen someone get captured um
with duck face yeah
yes those were quite curated by my
mysterious photographer
um but yeah I I was just such a bummer
this morning to like realize again here
in La so dependent on cars like the cars
won't start you're just screwed where
I'm like if I was in New York I could
just walk downstairs or crawl with your
bare hands my tail lady lives in L.A so
I have to but yeah no I'm back and I
guess this is this is life here is it
how do you guys do it
Kyla you came to New York did you love
it I love New York but you already know
I was fully [__] jet lagged like I
had gone straight from the Philippines
to New York so I don't remember much
yeah
um I think five days which is like just
enough to get over your jet lag you like
just start to feel good yeah I would
fall asleep at like 7 A.M and then have
to record at 9am I was just I was just
so confused I didn't know what the hell
was happening you were very out of it
like walking down the street with her I
was like I'm just not gonna talk to her
because she does I just I'm not there
she was like a zombie I was just
escorting around I don't know when
you're in charge that's
the kids are in charge sorry mommy's
tired baby's in charge wait but Annie
what so wait what have you been you I
was laying in bed okay try not to be
jealous listen no I was living
clusterics of your dream life
um but it's just real headaches not fake
ones
um no it was like basically like I want
to make a hat where you can clip your
extensions like to the Hat because that
was basically my life was like how do I
like
without having to do my hair do my hair
just to get dragged to anniewood to just
do like I was like every episode I was
like hi I'm in remission for one hour it
was crazy but I'm I'm out of them and
I'm back performing and stuff it's fun
it's like fun to be back but I was dying
Todd
he's fine he has the ring on person but
wait what he has the ring on person but
he's just not he's like scared to do it
wrong so he's like looking for too much
guys but he's telling you that's a ring
I mean I think he might have known no I
didn't I I knew my great answering and
then his mom and we put it together into
a ring I don't know what it looks like
though he has a ring he has like it was
my great aunts great great aunt's ring
it's like emerald and diamonds and then
his mom gave us uh tennis bracelet with
her diamonds in it so then he got on
Todd yes well maybe not getting engaged
doesn't mean much in this not with this
Trio does it well I have a crazy update
which is that Dave and I in our long
negotiations have broken up she's being
so happy she's like I choose New York in
our very long intense negotiations
um we have made some progress in
potentially having a wedding
wow were you like if you let me move to
New York we can get married and is it
going to be an elopement no so as you
guys know maybe or maybe not like
literally every day of the last five
years have been like if you want to
elope I'm ready to go let's go I'll
marry you any minute and he's like no he
wants a wedding and finally we sort of
made progress in New York where we I'm
maybe open to us getting married in
Chicago at the County Hall where my
parents got married by the same blind
judge well I think who is he's Mateo
Lane's Grandpa right here so does anyone
know if metallian's grandfather is still
with us
um but or maybe I was like should Mateo
Lane marry us like that would be really
good he's so busy he doesn't have time
for your your nonsense little way that
doesn't mean I can't ask him no you shut
hell's saying he'll steal the show I
know you definitely will be able to be
like shoot your shot or just choose
another blind person I like the idea of
the blind thing you can swap out Dave
with a woman have your real wedding but
so we might actually have a wedding this
fall in Chicago but I also told Dave I
don't want anyone from my side to be
there I just want it to be his family
and his friends
right we're out Danny I never thought I
was getting an invite to this one I was
gonna find out the wedding happened like
three months later
um but yeah so who knows maybe we'll get
married well congrats thank you I do
agree with you on this Esther what I
can't imagine planning like a big
wedding seems like yeah are you gonna
have a wedding
I want I'm thinking Vegas but like with
everyone you know so it's not like an
elopement thing but it's like a big
Vegas wedding yeah that sounds like I've
never even heard of that I feel like one
of the Kardashians just no I think uh
the
um Sophie Turner and Joe Jonas sort of
did that right they did this big fun
Vegas thing it's just we're so we love
Vegas so much it just seems like but for
my 40th birthday my brother my twin and
I are going to Vegas with our family and
Todd's family's gonna come and stuff my
mom's like you should just get married
there I'm like I ain't getting married
without my nieces and nephews not a
chance yeah wait so your brother has
agreed to see you on your birthdays he
keeps picking up it's actually so
annoying like when I pitched it I was
like let's spend our birthdays together
because I always try to but it's
basically me just being like hey Max can
I sleep on your couch during our
birthdays I know how you feel because I
have friends who have a birthday within
two weeks of mine and I'm always like
let's celebrate together and no one ever
wants to well maybe you should work on
yeah your personality I will try no my
brother it's like with my brother I'm
like chasing him forever but no he's
like excited about he's like I just want
to spend a lot of money and have a lot
of fun I was like
speaking my language
what do you think you guys will do
I don't know I don't think anyone in my
family is going to gamble I will
probably be the only one gambling
because everyone's too scared of money
um
but scared money don't make money baby
[Laughter]
wait have you guys heard about Dick
amnesia
yes okay I haven't but I definitely have
it is it the idea that you can't pick
and a previous Lover's dick out of a
lineup that's basically part of the idea
but it's it's more so I would say that
you don't remember any of the dicks that
you've previously interacted with so
it's like if you think of an ex you
probably can't realistically what's so
funny I'm just like have you ever like
been with a guy whose dick was so big
that you'll never forget it
the do you mean like I wouldn't know
what it looked like
this is a real thing by the way it's
dick Amnesia no I know you got up Tick
Tock it's real no I didn't where'd you
get it from a vice article they're going
background Tick Tock no it wasn't okay
device is going bankrupt because they
keep going I heard it from Eddie Wong oh
they are everyone everyone's going
bankrupt that's like a given David's
Bridal is going bankrupt wait bed bath
beyond that one is too close to us is it
real or but I feel like they've been
going bankrupt for the past three years
and always have the 70s
Bed Bath and Beyond bankrupt is just a
part of a sale did their CEO even jump
off a building oh is that what happened
I think so sorry David's Bridal I think
they deserve to go out of business why
because haven't you had like awkward
bridesmaid dress fittings there and
whatever they always all the dresses
look the same it's so basic it's like
commodifies like a special a day that's
supposed to be like special and unique
is it affordable
medium
okay so it's not even you know you've
never been to David's Bridal I guess you
guys never walked in the king says
before okay I didn't know last week
wait a second so dick Amnesia okay so
because there are some dicks I wish I
could forget I know are you telling like
if I think of my exes I cannot picture
what their dicks look like
um I okay so you're talking to a girl
who's hat who's ran out of a room
because she saw a downward pointing
penis oh we've all been with the with
the Gonzo yeah it's it's a terrifying
experience that I could pick out of the
lineup are you going where's that with
my eyes closed like what organ is that
gonna hit
I called the fruit loop
do you remember
your dicks
I mean some it's like I think I remember
the act and whether or not they were
good lovers I don't necessarily like
know like Bobby's I'll never forget
because that was 10 years none of us
will no one will ever forget that but I
mean like I remember if someone was like
a good lover but not necessarily like
I'm trying to use my ex Steve as an
example
um I was with him for five years
um yeah I don't think I could pick his
dick out of a lineup he had a great
penis honestly I don't think I could
pick anyone's dick out of a lineup like
I I'm used to seeing the dick like
surrounded by things like I'm not very
dick pic like accepting so but do you
think it's just seeing just like a
a dick alone yeah
you're looking at stick Amnesia it's
holistic it's like we're looking at the
whole being right I don't think women I
remember them all I can't believe I mean
why I love you but I remember them all
every single one of them I had a
boyfriend who had like a big dick but it
was like it was like his foreskin was
like he he was circumcised but it was
still baggy on his dick it was like
weird I've had a couple like like guys
that like it's like their circumcision
only got to like a mock turtleneck like
it never got really like down to a crew
neck yeah but that's a safer route
because I've been with a guy who had too
much removed and so when he would have
full blood flow it would hurt because
his skin would crack because there
wasn't enough skin to stretch I remember
none I don't even remember days like
when whenever I see it I'm like whoa
that's your dick like I don't remember a
dick once it's not in my what do you
feel when you look at your own deck I
have a question do you think that guys
remember how water [__] look like yes
they do I think everyone remembers
everything this is crazy this is real
this is science I think I'm pretty sure
wait I want to know if like my exes can
you know like yeah that's kaleila's
[__] because I think I have a very
average fast uh I wish don't brag but
it's so awesome
is so ideal in every way I think I had a
I had a waxer I think everybody told you
guys this I had a waxer in New York who
walks like everyone like she whacked so
many vaginas a day and when she
recognized me on the subway I was like
oh no do you remember no she did you
didn't have your vagina out on the
subway I know but it's like it takes a
special vajazz no remember well maybe
she has [__] Amnesia yeah I think she
remembers but I remember just being like
Oh I don't want her to remember wait
what are you like during a wax are you
like silent or crying or what do you
like what I just got legs cookie b-hole
armpits wax uh-huh all together I got
sugared I was two hours
is so painful I like like my I'm not
even gonna lie I kind of like getting my
[__] waxed I do like how it feels
well it doesn't hurt me it doesn't hurt
it's like it's like a slap which by the
way you didn't respond to my slap fight
request wait a minute I don't remember
this you sent me a video of back in the
day oh when you hit me in the face
I was like we should just slap By Radio
silence yeah no I'm not giving him a
slap fight it should fly across the room
why would I agree to that like flowers
yeah it's completely you would deal with
me yeah but you know what I feel really
bad because my my hands and my paws are
massive like it would be my paws are
huge the butthole in my opinion doesn't
hurt because it comes aft at the very
end of the bikini wax and so you're like
I've already been through hell like the
butthole can't do anything what if I was
like it does well they're going like
[__] first with my wax well I think
the butthole gets just daily
um beatings right like there's always
action there so I think I think it's
used to large things being you know you
know going out of it so I'm a bragger I
honestly going into it I was like
do you take big shits what the [__] is
this you're so small they're small to us
but big to her it looks like a Randy
show it looks like you know I lean
towards constipation so if you're just
bragging that you're just taking big
dumps every day like that's really
disrespectful I mean I really want to
know do you do you poop big all the time
I caca is perfect
um wait but what are you like during a
wax I was I mean I was like twitching I
was it was just non-stop pain for two
hours here's what it is I got the whole
thing waxed off just to try it and I've
I've never had the top hair I've always
always left a Dorito
that so that was untouched never been
waxed area that's the worst it was the
most painful worst area I almost quit
and just had like what was like a my
[__] almost looked like a barista with
like a half shaved head I was like are
we about to leave this because I was
wait a second so you had a Dorito there
for years do you trim it or do you let
it go high well I have a little fun with
it I go high trim it down because it's
it's what you can make it like a a very
long Dorito also a Pringles can it's one
of those 3D ones I don't think we should
be giving Doritos free advertising I
think we should give it a generic name
like cheesy tortilla chip do you know
what I like about this what your head's
in the game your head to the game baby
I'm just sick of like the 90s foods that
like dominate my brain all the time like
they they have there's like a Doritos
poster ingrained in my brain it's not
but the Olympic takes care of that right
I wish you guys it's insane how many
people
I mean like everyone I look at is just
real thin now and I'm like I can totally
tell the weight loss is fast this is me
being out of town for two months and I
totally am not experiencing this at all
is everyone here thin all of a sudden
Yes except for Annie and I everyone try
to bring me with you
I had questions laying in bed all day I
didn't have closer headaches that I've
gotten bigger so you're good I can't
tell what you look like because you're
dressed like a potato salad
I want to admit something so I'm trying
to pack on like a lot of muscle and so
I'm I'm in my full like bulk phase we
had a guest on um tigerbelly two days
ago David so and on he on tigerbelly he
was like I saw this person at the gym
like rolling around stretching and I was
like dude that's a buff ass dude is that
like a Buff Ass Dude or a Buff Ass Like
trans girl and then and it was me he was
like oh my God it's called I and I'm
fine I've bulked before I see now on
camera yes it's there's just a lot of
meat on my body your dress this is so
unfair
and I wanted to see her I but I feel
really strong I'm lifting a lot I'm
lifting heavy and I I like being uh you
know a you could just a bulky [__]
maybe maybe maybe but I'm not I'm not
toned yet because I've just packed on
the muscle and there's what are you
going to turn on
I'm not toning yet
pack on the way what kind of just a lot
of protein and I'm not skimping on carbs
I'm eating well yeah I'm not in a
calorie deficit I'm just like eating
healthy but not restricting either I'm
not trying to copy you but I literally
have been kind of low-key doing the same
thing but you have to exercise I've been
doing Pilates me too I'm so into it it
makes me it does make me feel like I
kept woman and it's like I don't like
the vibe with a reformer I love it I
love being like all tied up in there I
love the reformer but like The Branding
that Pilates has in my mind is like kept
woman like housewife like who runs like
a charity event like it's so not because
it's expensive because it's expensive
yeah that's probably that's exactly why
yeah Pilates is the best are you doing
classes or privates I'm doing class I've
been doing classes in New York and I'm
like I'm gonna do it here too yeah
that's the best I just I find that it's
like
it's hard but it's also fun and it's
kind of easy too right like it tricks
you yeah but it also works on like these
tiny muscles that you don't normally do
by doing like a regular deadlift you
know so but so like feeling the muscles
work it's given me more freedom to be
like all right I am gonna pack on my
protein and like eat like a fitness
girly and like but Pilates is very
toning
it is like you're not packing on the
muscle there you really are kind of
shredding well Esther's like uh never
mind I'm back what were you eating
eating I eat everything I we had pizza I
mean Dave is like I was telling Dave
like he this is what makes him the best
person but also the worst like he is
always no matter what down to eat or
take a nap like any given point what a
dream boy I know but it's also not good
because like you know
when you're with someone and they're
just like let's go get pizza I'm like I
didn't need to hear that but I will say
this about naps I never feel more bonded
with a partner than when we take random
like unplanned now oh yeah you just pass
out together like really tightly wrapped
around each other is the best most
bonding feeling in the world for me or a
nap holding a baby
oh my God what did New York do to this
who's baby when I used to babysit
sometimes the baby would fall asleep and
then I would just kind of fall asleep
with it I got the worst babysitter ever
the Roses you're suffocating with your
tits
I know
you've taken the morning after pill
being single isn't easy but I'm not
ready to read at my baby
being single with a breeding Kink is not
easy oh my God
I was just told that's what I have I
like to play with fire a little bit but
thank God for Julie because it gives me
the option to fulfill my Kinks but also
you know stop an unwanted pregnancy look
you like sex original recipe as we've
learned
um I'll say this I am 35 and engaged it
is a weird time in your life to need a
morning after pill but sometimes you're
not ready and I'm very appreciative of
Julie because it actually makes the
experience feel kind of fun and like
you're a hot girl and not like you're a
sad person buying a sad box that's not
behind the counter yeah I mean like this
Julie is just something I wish I had in
my teens and in my 20s looking at that
purple pink box it's just so much less
serious and scary than what's already
out there also how cool to be the girl
at the party that's like oh yeah I have
this just in case you know just Flex
that and weirdly my name is also Julie
Julie is an FDA approved morning after
pill that helps stop pregnancy before it
starts if you've ever had unprotected
sex forgot your birth control had a
condom break or you're just not totally
sure we are excited to talk about a new
company that is giving emergency
contraception a much needed Rebrand and
this is how Julie works you guys so
Julie stops your body from releasing an
egg using using the same active
ingredient as plan b or other morning
after pills essentially Julie works by
preventing or delaying your ovulation
with no egg there's no fertilization and
therefore no pregnancy and it's no risk
to Future fertility it's legal in all 50
states you do not need an ID
prescription or credit card to get it
and they just launched at CBS you can
also find it at Target and Walmart
across the U.S and Julie is not just a
morning after pill it's a morning after
pill brand that is working to increase
access to emergency contraception for
women across the country which is very
important right now Julie has a one for
one donation program that that means
every time you purchase a Julie at a
store or online the company will donate
one pill to someone who needs it Julie
partners with over 25 organizations
across the country to provide donations
to those disproportionately impacted by
Health inequalities you can go to
juliecare.co to learn more or find Julia
your nearest CVS Target or Walmart today
that's juliecare.co to learn more this
show is sponsored by betterhelp it is so
easy to get caught up in what everyone
else needs from you and never take a
moment to think about what you need from
yourself but we when we spend all of our
time giving it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out and I
always believe it's like if you don't
fill your own cup you cannot fill
someone else's you need to make sure
that your needs are met you need to make
sure that you're operating at your best
self and there's really no better way to
ensure that than seeing a therapist what
what else can you do that's truly for
you for your mental health for your
happiness to better your future then
talk to a professional what I love about
betterhelp is it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule they also have a
journal feature on the app where you can
write down your heavy thoughts and share
them with your therapist on your next
appointment and you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge I struggled so much finding a
therapist in my 20s and like just all
those hurdles parking
um just finding someone that was the
right fit for you the fact that better
help has now made it so convenient and
affordable you can do it from home you
can switch therapists easy at any time
you can find someone who's your
specialty I think if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge
find more balance with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com trash Tuesday
foreign
I had I had it all planned Randy and
Todd were coming I got like really Soho
Grand Hotel Randy was gonna come yes I
got wow my hotel was not as fancy it
would have been so fun it would have
been so fun I bought so many clothes I
spent so I guys I was so ready to go it
was such a bummer I was so we'll go back
yeah why don't we do like an end of
summer thing yeah and then we do have to
go to Vegas and [__] and maybe tour
maybe maybe possibly
so on Raya I saw
me a guy not like on onrya you can see
like what are you seeking what are you
looking for and I've never x'ed out of a
profile so fast and because this is what
it said seeking a partner who makes
every day feel extraordinary
like think about what we just said naps
and food like imagine being with a guy
who wants that type of girl to make
every like mundane Day Extraordinary
what is that you make it extraordinary
yeah speaking a partner who makes every
day feel extraordinary no bro you make
it extraordinary if that's what you want
yeah it should say I will make every day
extraordinary for you
and even that is gross like no thank you
I like that he's looking for a Pilates
girl why just a capped woman no he's
looking for like a someone to like Shake
keys in front of his face and be like
entertain him I think any actually I
think you are gonna have a baby soon
this is crazy all your baby references
and then you get the little thing oh my
God
no oh you started doing Pilates yeah
I just started to get my hot girl body
going wait a second I just remembered I
still well I told you New York I've had
a broken toe for two months I had a
broken toe in the field I broke it in
the Philippines with two opposite
experiences everyone know about this
broken toe and the first I'm hearing
about this and it's still broken and
I've walked everywhere traveled
everywhere not bad it's smashed broken I
mean it's still this big no I usually
she works out way harder than you have
to admit she has a better tolerance for
pain I could not walk you don't
understand it wasn't a pain tolerance
when something when you're and it makes
it worse that's not having to you don't
want to you don't want to tolerate that
kind of pain you have to know which pain
to tolerate and which pain I want to
hurt your doctors because I feel like
they're just little kids that you baby
support in doctors outfits and they
brush their hair while they're
diagnosing me but did you feel like
incapacitated like fully disabled and
handicapped it does also every day yes
I can't be the only person who broke
their pinky dough toe which I it might
have only been a fracture but a fracture
is a break that's real yeah
I can't be the only one who couldn't
walk from that
maybe because mine is the second toe so
it's sort of supported by the toes
around it and yours is just hanging off
okay this
I thought you're about to pull your your
feet I was like we're about to get some
views baby
which like you can walk from room to
room yeah but Esther that is how you
walk
in regular that's your diaper butt walk
I know that's what those Paparazzi were
just randomly catching well that's when
I after sitting for more than five
minutes I my hips freeze up I need to
warm up
um I have wait what were we just what
did you just bring up my broken toe no
oh yeah okay so you're so you're
claiming that you broke your toe and you
can just do everything normal no no no I
just no I it it hurts it hurts when I
sleep I feel it in my sleep I feel it
when I wake up I feel it when I walk I'm
just saying it didn't require a
wheelchair oh well what makes you feel
the need to say that I mean weren't you
in Japan in a wheel day pushing you
around in a wheelchair was I I can't
is that what happened I don't remember I
I didn't see that picture of you you
know the paparazzi thing oh my God it's
the problem
[Laughter]
also I just saw Wicked and I was like oh
we should do wicked theme but then I
[__] realized that you'll be uh
Glinda you'll be alphaba and I'll be
alphaba's sister who's in a wheelchair
because her legs don't work it's so I'm
so I'm not pitching that as a theme but
you know where you are that's the truth
it's like it's not like anyone's done it
to you you are a wheelchair girl wait
that's really a thing now I heard like
um trans ableism people identifying as
like handicapped have you heard this
fancy so there are people out there who
identify as handicapped unless even
though they have no true disability and
um well who's to say who has true and
who has fallen how's your neck pain
during uh Pilates honestly I have really
cured a lot of my physical ailments I'm
proud are you a trans ableist what do
you mean do you do it do you identify as
handicap
foreign
it's not a no yeah it was a thoughtful
because you did claim to not have neck
muscles at one point
I didn't for many years or back muscles
actually oh my God I didn't and it's
really it's actually really scary it's
actually really sad
it is sad it's sad in a different way
than I think you think yeah it's quite
sad and I have realized lately now that
we're talking about this that chairs are
not made for people my size okay that's
why I have to sit in funny positions and
that's why I have well what is it how
does she explain her weird squash there
are kids sections in every store that is
a good point yeah do you have to go like
in Target to use the little thing I
would probably be a lot better off if I
did make choices like that yeah if we're
some platforms why don't you try
because then I'm like becoming like
everyone else I think you should you're
not like anyone
very unique
you try towards basic it's very weird
he's begging to be basic
talk live called me mid and I was like
that is the best compliment I could ever
have being mid like who doesn't want to
be mid they meant middle aged
mid is not a slam it is me gorgeous mid
[__] mid everything it's okay I think
I've always strived for Mid mid's okay
mid tits oh my tits are think subpar mid
face wait no you don't have mid tits no
you're good your tits are good no you
have Supreme both of you
mine are just under mid I think because
I had you know like I had implants took
them out there's just a lot I've ravaged
I've ravaged you basically probably had
the experience of like breastfeeding
without breastfeeding probably where
they get really big and then small again
yeah but you know no I've seen that
enough they don't sad yeah so because I
didn't have a mono I only had them for
like a year and a half so probably your
tits are perfect but you remember what
they looked like no I'll show you so
when I flexed indentation right here but
so I cannot Fleck when I'm naked in
front of a boy because I have to keep
thinking don't like use your muscles or
your PEC muscles or Flex it's so funny
to imagine you're just flexing
can I tell this room that would be like
well no like if I'm on top right if I'm
on top I have to be mindful to not put
my hands like on his chest or else you
will see my pecs sort of what are they
right at that point wait yeah
hands are not on the man are they they
go different different ways no I I'm on
I do multiple so I sometimes I lay flat
fully on them sometimes I do this it
depends it depends but I move around
Esther what would you do if you're ever
gonna put the effort in to be on top
wait so you're like this
it's a tiny hallway
sometimes they'll be like sometimes my
hands will be like here
[Laughter]
they really are like because I'm not
kidding and I know what it looks like
but it's not that I swear he's not dead
oh no The Perils of dating an older man
oh like by the way there's so many good
tick tocks out there I'm learning a lot
about being on top like they tick-top
they're teaching us this is a tick tock
this is why they want to ban it because
all of us girls are getting together and
learning how to get get off and it's
only like how many how long are tick
tocks how long did they go 45 seconds
and then you gotta just get off in 45
seconds
how do you guys feel about people
um everyone being verified now because
they can pay for it oh I'm glad you
brought this up it's so there's nothing
funnier than going on to Twitter the day
it happens
because it was a treat okay so you know
how it worked on Twitter it was like you
could pay for your your check mark or
and and he kept saying we're gonna take
your check marks away You're Gonna Take
check marks away unless you pay this
like monthly thing
and then they he took them away one day
and you could see who still had their
check marks and it was literally just
Esther and I didn't pay okay No One
Believes Me okay it's crazy I did not
pay I think because you're maybe a lot
more active on Twitter I don't know what
it is there's no Rhyme or Reason because
at first I was like I was trying to
figure out what the I think Carlos paid
for behind her back yes no I will show
you receipts I'll figure out how to I
mean I have just general Amnesia not
yeah
this is crazy if you think that my half
Jewish ass would pay eight dollars a
month for something but that other half
really wants that status
I promise you I don't understand what
happened also someone said that there's
a hack where if you write blue check in
your Twitter bio it will give you but
you didn't do that no wait a second but
wait a year I feel like you're
intimidated by my blue check I promise
you I'm not you're I just want to know
you know the joy probably when you were
the only person it's embarrassing no
it's very embarrassing I came forward
and was like please remove this like I
don't want it because it makes me look
like or was it no I know or was it six
months of you directly tweeting at Elon
okay I will have your baby
right you did do that I did that's true
I've been campaigning a while to be I've
been a pick me for a while on Twitter
but on Instagram like I'm seeing
um
people everyone's got just a blue check
then you have to do like a double check
and then you see that they have like 31
followers and you're like okay it is
like weird because it's like when brands
are hitting you up and stuff you want to
know if they're like I think it's a
complete Miss I think this was like a is
a complete Miss and a complete failure
like
but I get that also being verified in
general is stupid and like no one should
have it but this version of it is really
stupid it's just like I've been verified
so long it's like
who cares if you want it what on Twitter
don't worry being not verified is the
verified you and all like the followers
are verified I mean Trisha Paytas kept
her blue check mysteriously
so I don't know I I one of her multiple
personalities might have done it
her as a Dairy Queen employee signed up
oh my God those are multiple
personalities or the outfits she's on
it's just different no I know I and Dave
is intimidated too I I'm used to this
don't worry uh Dave accused me of paying
as well I had I mean I just want to say
to be the type of person that even your
fiance who live with doesn't believe you
I mean that is what I'm intimidated by
to have that power
oh
it was a nice day I know I I volunteer I
said I come forward I would like this
taken away yeah I was in so much pain
and I do want to thank you you really
did help me you're welcome give me a
good giggle you're very welcome
okay so ladies
um here's the deal initially we thought
it was a good idea to gift our fathers
um male grooming kits but it turns out
it's a good idea to gift your partner
yeah a male grooming kid that's what we
want to say I mean Happy Father's Day
across the board even to your own
fathers but maybe give it to your
partner maybe Not Your Father's Day for
you you know or if you have that
relationship with your dad why not maybe
your mom's like hey like you know like
do me a solid and can you get your or
there's a male co-worker on an Andre sir
Pete and you need to get them the the
beard hedger Pro kit which inside he
will find a signature beard hedge
trimmer beard shampoo and conditioner
beard oil beard balm and two free gifts
with their signature beard comb and
scissors actually that's a really cute
gift for a dad I know the beard package
yeah I was just thinking if I if I got
my dad manscaped my I would have to come
in person because my mom would have to
take one side and I would have oh yeah
oh the good bat wings listen he'll be 80
by the time this comes out with 20 hair
cutting lengths and a singular guard
he'll be able to craft his look like
never before without a mess in the
drawers
guys let me just say something okay
you don't know when you're gonna wake up
one day you're gonna go to bed you're
gonna wake up one day you're gonna be 82
years old okay it's gonna be very hard
to shave your sack then so I don't want
you to take these these shavable sack
ears for granted it's time and with and
manscape you guys like you're not gonna
get any Nicks this is beautiful this
beautiful bundle is absolutely daddy
material you hear that Daddy material it
includes their signature lawnmower 4.0
brand new weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose
hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant super important crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold his goodies get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trash Tuesday at manscaped.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscaped.com
and use code trash Tuesday make this
Father's Day one he won't forget with
manscaped
oh
you know one thing that I realized that
I do in my relationship that if a guy
did this I would be so turned off and
grossed out but I can't stop myself is
whenever I do the slightest thing that
is like beneficial for the households
yeah I know that's the slightest yeah we
want to hear the slide okay I'll give
you
Dave is thirsty and I have water on hand
I need that's an accidental Good Deed
I'm not what happens three times in a
row baby okay she's just been doing
Pilates so she's up in her uh her
hydration three times in a row he needed
water I had it I need so much validation
and praise for that I'm like
holy [__] like I did that like I did
that for you and I feel like if a guy
did that I would be so repulsed I'd be
like ew that is the bare minimum of what
I expect out of you well who does like
your dishes Dave
we both we do them we both do them yeah
yeah
equally
probably there's that saying which is
Dave told me this very early in our
relationship and it it has proven to be
very useful which is like in a
relationship I think in any partnership
you go in assuming you're going to do 60
of the work and they'll do 40 and so
then you like never get like resentful
you there's not a chance on how you do
six sixty percent of anything I know you
think that of maybe 60 this is
projecting because I think I would never
I would never tell you any lie about the
90 to 10 I would never I would never
like
it's Heaven it's amazing it's so nice
it's so good but you have to be very
nice you can't ever be mad at the Dave
has fully trained me and it's it is sad
it's sick and sad like I do my chores
now it's horrible that's good this way
but you so he does 90 of the efforts and
how do you we found a very good new
cleaning lady too that makes us all so
happy how do you
get away with that
he offered it up in a weak moment and
here's the thing we're very like
anyone's dreams can come true in the
relationship we support each other
anything we want to do and I as long as
the dishes are clean but luckily no
sometimes they're not clean but I like
every once in a while I'll do them but
it's not often like they'll just stay
there sometimes they'll be like Todd you
really like let me mess this place up
it's always my
they'll pile up I don't care it doesn't
bother me you know what Dave has done
that really helps me is he will give me
credit he knows that I'm a girl who
needs credit and so I do the dishes and
he's like thank you so much and yeah
you're uh you're a gold star baby yeah
so gold star I have a praise King what
if he gave you like little like raffle
tickets that would probably just got so
excited oh my God they're like who's
gonna win but it's all just your tickets
now in this raffle we got the chills
again
Oscar wins doing the dishes again
I want that so bad
um but isn't that something that was
trained when you're younger with the
gold stars yes it's so helpful it really
is like any tiny little good job it just
goes do you see is wouldn't that be
worth doing dishes for I have wait you
have to ask me that or you have to
answer me this okay
I have been thinking about writing out a
script of what I want Todd to say to me
when I'm upset yes I don't want him to
read it but I want him to memorize it
okay and I don't we all get one of those
we should all give that to everybody I
think so just the exact thing you want
to hear yes because it doesn't matter if
someone means it right because the truth
is if we're healthy we're telling it to
ourselves like it's always like
something we really just need to tell
ourselves but mind very situation is
situation you might have to be smart
enough to kind of um you have a yellow
one and you have a black one is it a
sunny day
so it's got to be like if three days
before my period different script it's
crazy how
much I know now I used to not know when
I was getting my period now I just know
so much same same yes but it's just
because I've worked on myself where I'm
not in a rage at all times so it's it is
just wild I start crying at like I got
so moved by the the
um Barbie with Down Syndrome
there's a Barbie that has Down syndrome
now and I was I mean not that I wouldn't
be moved by oh look how fancy type
Barbie
b-a-r-b-y that's a joke I'm not gonna
take right now that would be very rude
to the Down Syndrome Barbie doll no
that's your Barbie no because I think
even the Barbie doll would have spelled
it but that's okay
that's all right he's filling in for
he's now our new Carlos
I think you guys got an upgrade no we're
so happy okay it's a Barbie no no no no
please please so we're all yeah no we
don't want to type it up
with Down Syndrome it's so cute
she does look just normal honestly
yeah she's so cute are you so happy
about this so you you had an emotional
moment I have very like I mean not that
I would have been moved by this but I
mean I was like posting about it I was
just really in it no I'm sick of I'm so
sick of the companies trying to
to make good on torturing us for our
whole lives like this does not work are
you mad because they don't have like an
Esther looking one yet that they skipped
you for the Down syndrome kids like a
little bit honestly Esther I'm a short
brown-haired girl like they have
wheelchair Barbies they they don't
actually they do oh I just saw a video
of a of a girl in the wheelchair short
brown Barbie is not gonna come out how
you want to
I'm sorry the language barrier is not
working out for us here you I understand
Barbie has always been a positive
experience for you because you have
blonde hair and blue eyes
but also they're green and it's dyed but
it's okay I do think that kalila should
have been cast in the Barbie movie
because there is no Barbie there's no
kalila Barbie in the movie with my mid
tits on my mid-tits Barbie oh we're back
the hottest one complaining about her
look oh my God you guys here we are
again nothing's changed Esther works out
I'm happy about that because for years
but when you're always like I'm really
dedicated to my once a week
you're how many times you're doing
Pilates a week two three four I mean I
when I was in New York I took a workout
class like
on average probably four days a week
it's a musical theater dance oh my God
some ballet lots of walking yeah it is
weird you never lived in New York
thank you so much I believe this was a
clerical error I don't know how I ended
up in La it doesn't make any sense the
second I'm in New York I'm like this is
it reminds me of how I grew up like
outside of Chicago like the palm trees
everywhere is like being on vacation
that's not the vibe like people there
are people like me everywhere in New
York there are short pale Jewish one
with brown hair everywhere I just feel
like
and their husbands are wearing like
Curly
and they throw eggs and Annie what is
what does what do you want your script
to Todd or what do you want your script
to say
when I just want I literally just want
someone to say everything is gonna work
out exactly how you want it to work out
don't worry everything's happening the
way it's supposed to happen
I do like that that's all I want just a
confidence in where things are going and
that anything that's happening in the
moment is just leading to what you know
what this is so sad but you might
benefit from this something that I've
been doing lately is like I'll make
these little videos for myself that are
very similar oh I can't wait to hack
your phone
they're like you're doing great like you
just did this and reminding me for when
I'm low is it a voice note or a video
it's a video okay it's a selfie mode
video that's good you're feeling
yourself now you want to see yourself
you want to see your face saying it so
that you can then go call call up those
later when you're I think that's a good
idea I like that yeah and then you'll be
like oh okay this because another thing
it's like you are not your moods like
and that's what I've learned with the
period is like that week around it for
me I don't get angry and I don't get sad
I get lethargic
I start to feel like everything is
impossible I feel like how could I've
made this plan like I just get so low
and so I've learned to be like okay when
that is happening I don't trust that
person that person is not like me
they're not in charge I'm not my those
moods it's the little wheelchair witch
from Wicked and without like
invalidating like how you're feeling in
that moment you I do have to remind
myself like my feelings are not factual
like right now
because boy when I get in my head it's
like 50 times bigger than it actually is
so I'm like my feelings are not fact my
feelings are not fat that's a big one
that Whitney I feel like has said for
over the years uh feelings are not facts
they're not she's not a good one to me
too where she's like don't go to the
don't go to the problem for the solution
yeah she's so good at those like um you
can just just been in therapy what is
another thing um one of my professors in
nursing school said don't borrow bad
news so it's like for me like uh for
instance like perfect example is like my
mom she had
um blood work done and there was one
thing that was off in her numbers and
already she's like I have cancer and so
it's basically don't don't live in like
the bad news the results like don't live
in what you think it is like going down
the rabbit hole of WebMD and you know
like there's nothing as bad has happened
do you think like um that means like
when Esther was like I think we need to
like defend Anne Frank don't you you
remember when you had a your nude yeah I
don't I agree with my take on Anne Frank
you're like let's go back I gotta live I
gotta
feel the pain for Anne Frank no I just
think it's embarrassing to have your
journals read by a million well yours
are going to be videos if you're going
like you go girl
that's gonna be so embarrassing when
that's what people little actually
that's why I'm advocating for Anne Frank
I'm advocating for Anne Frank's diary to
never be read again that's so [__] up
off the presses hey Frank you're out of
here I pitched something to Esther I
kind of want to try I feel like I'm so
behind on like the beauty trends I want
to try micro needling and I was thinking
maybe we could take a field trip to all
get microneedled micro needled I want to
get um
I think I want to do laser after all
that waxing what is that late I want
laser hair removal oh oh me too no I
honestly don't want laser hair removal
I'm really happy with my wax routine I
love how many how often do you go well I
haven't gone in two months so it's not
looking good right now but
I'll show you mine
I haven't gone in a month I'll show you
mine
let me see
oh wow but you have really pretty pubes
feathers are really dark
what do you mean pretty it's hot it's
like what do you mean pretty tell me
more yeah like that's that's two months
expand on that two months wow you do
grow
yeah I'm not Asian I'm Jewish different
over here Asians have pubes that's a
misconception completely
oh my God how long's family
oh very clean mine's about a month
he said it looks like a little boy's
butt but we're gonna just not pretend he
didn't say that
I like it now I used to not like it what
I didn't like being the idea of being
fully naked I feel like I'm naked for
the first time in my whole life without
the Lord your [__] skin is so pretty I
know it's smooth right yeah but mine is
um about over here
no
[Music]
this is a good banana better than
Carlos's joyous
were always all [__] bruised and
yes yeah what did he do to those bananas
I don't know but I heard a rumor of what
he's doing on the bad friend store do
you know what
his job is he's not allowed to go
anywhere he's to stay on the bus and he
um he empties out the septic tank
so there's no subject hanging in my
diaper
clean the diaper not change it it's
gonna be like wow
he's Jewish she had to save that money
for her blue check mark
are you dressed like your blue check
mark tonight
that was so funny when it was just you
as a turf
I guess Elon just thought I was a
special girl just watching the back
pedaling of everyone like I'll I'll
believe you that you had a fluke just so
we can stay friends but just I would not
lie that's so embarrassing like it's
such an obvious
like it's so humility there's no winning
in this position
because no one believes that I didn't
pay so it seems like I'm lying like why
would I put why are you going lying why
are you going to John Molina you made it
not me because I did hear that when you
said it you guys know what a human
decanter is as like a party trick
um a man will
um put a um a catheter up his pee hole
empty out his bladder and then refill
his bladder with wine and then piss into
people's mouths stop no we're not
what did Pete suggest we try it
which one of you would do it I'll pee in
your mouth no no they have to pee in
each other's mouth but it's and the
reason the only reason I know about this
is because an ER doctor I will piss all
over you the an ER doctor as well
because I was trying to out for each
other Shake on it wait so I guess an ER
doctor was talking about how a person
came in with a set of symptoms and they
found out that he had like a kidney
infection a UTI because he was doing
this for a senior like a retirement home
why because I guess um old people have
kinks too and they want wine out of a
out of the tap
well
I found out some stuff on the road by
the way I have some really cute things
from the road to give you guys wow you
guys are so jaded this is similar this
is like related
wait what what do you mean we're so
jaded I basically said someone was
pissing wine out of their penises into
old people's mouth and you're like
Ernest New York I know she's like pissed
wine same thing no that is so unhealthy
did you drink in New York alcohol yeah
why would I suddenly drink alcohol cause
you change oh do you know that she quit
weed
yeah well I'm like I'm dabbling now but
yeah I'm not I mean I got high every
single night for two years like every
night did not miss me in a night where I
would forget I would just like take a 20
milligram edible right before I went to
bed just like keep it up I was it was a
little bit a lot and what was the
turning point there kind of was no
turning point it just it's truly
happened the way Dave had low-key always
kind of said he's like you just get sick
of it it's like because I would always
be like don't you want to get high with
me to be like I don't feel like he's
like I did this I so I just was like oh
I'm like too it's too much yeah so now
it's like a little random treat is
better it's good I wish I could do a
random treat oh God I can't the minute I
do it once I have to like have a switch
it's like you don't do this or you do do
this what do you have now as random
treats
um
it's nothing I've been drinking no
mushrooms are like for a while ruined
wait why really because I had to take
them during my cluster headaches and it
was like like I'm like about to cry it
was so bad so now you associate I was
like tripping so hard and then they're
just so pain it's like so much pain that
sounds nice so I'm like I'm like in pain
and then also tripping it was like hell
it was just so so now you're associating
just yeah I'm ripping with the pain and
like feeling like you have to trip it's
like you don't want to be like yeah you
know and I was like trying different
dosages because nothing was like really
working and it's just like it's just
it's like feeling forced to do
hallucinogens like I was like I feel
like I know I was like I feel like this
is like a government study like if this
doesn't help the like military then yeah
what is this for well you're doing God's
work and it wasn't it it just didn't so
now I'm like even though I don't want to
be like done with them forever because I
think they're like an amazing tool and
medicine but I just can't do anything
for a while so I'm doing nothing I'm not
drinking coffee anymore what
drinking tea because I couldn't it was
like triggering though
yeah yeah I was doing nothing
wow yeah I I haven't drank coffee in
years but I am dabbling in back into
decaf
I love oh she's wild I love coffee is my
coffee is my boyfriend yeah as Taylor
Swift would say it is my boyfriend I
love it so I thought it was like a cute
thing you came up with oh that too
yeah no that is
I know what like alcoholics must feel
like when someone says they don't drink
because and they they are drinkers
because like when you guys say you don't
drink coffee I'm like
yeah it makes you feel weird yeah well
okay so this is challenging my reality
I've quit drinking coffee like a bunch
of times and
basically I'm trying to find the
correlation between my cluster headaches
and maybe like sleep problems so like
maybe I'm like near sleep apnea
situation I will I know
um but so I've been doing more like
taping my mouth spray tan now so we're
not taping but priorities but I am
trying to really be conscious of keeping
my mouth closed while I sleep keeping my
nose open
um just stuff like that you should have
Todd hold your nose open while you sleep
Todd if he falls asleep before me
wait I want to talk about this no I am
oh my God I want to talk about this I'm
literally doing a whole bit about this I
cannot and this is just like this is a
non-negotiable for me if you were a guy
that cannot stay awake past my sleeping
time we are never gonna make it a
hundred percent agree this is you have
to protect me yeah no I know but that
feeling I think that's what it is I like
the the I like knowing that someone is
watching over me that someone is I don't
care if there's noise involved I don't
care if you're watching TV I just need
to know that you're awake yes while I'm
asleep that that that puts me in a deep
Slumber when he starts snoring I'm like
I have to put my headphones on and start
just listening to meditate I'm like oh
my God what is going to get me through
this but that whole thing you were
saying like I do spin out I'm in the
dark and my mind starts going nuts I
feel a lot of anxiety for me it comes
from too like growing up my parents went
to bed every single night at 9 00 pm and
so I was always making so much
so I was always like alone awake at
night and it was just the worst feeling
like the worst the best I've ever slept
is in college when I lived so funny for
your parents to go to bed and just be
like
like and then I go to other people's
houses and their parents are like up
till midnight but I'll tell you
something my dad being up late my dad
gave me like
um like couch hang syndrome like I would
rather like sleep on a couch in case
something I like that happens yes
because I don't want fomo I'm trying to
really get to the root of my phone
because this New York week was
hard really yes it was so sad wait did
you did you um see my Chinese medicine
guy no oh yes I did okay did it help at
all I mean I like to say it's Kevin
Biggins but it is sorry it is the bacons
yeah
um no no but I did see him and just
nothing it's like so weird nothing works
once the cycle starts like maybe all
this stuff can help before the cycle
starts once the cycle starts it's like
it's like so electric the guy kept going
to my my Rolfing guy and he was like I'm
so sorry I can't he's like well we're
just like learning I was just figuring
out more of like where my nerves connect
and stuff like that but it wasn't like
for relief but it was more comfortable
to know kind of you know do they is
there research on like what causes it to
start it's like different for everyone
it's like different seasons for you it's
like every two years it's like but that
happens for most people so there's
there's like episodic ones and then
there's people that have them
chronically which I mean they're called
suicide headaches but I'm assuming it's
The Chronic ones that kill them yeah
I mean I know it's going to end
eventually but it is almost it's almost
like clockwork six weeks and then it's
just gone and then there's usually a day
where I think it's gone I'm like oh and
they come back and then yeah crying in a
grocery store
but
um
yeah it's really weird it's like all of
a sudden like my sinuses will like puff
up my eye gets all puffy and runny it's
just so I can't even imagine when I get
a migraine which lasts a day maybe too
if it's terrible it's like
it's just you feel so helpless you feel
it's so you can't do it you can't look
at your phone you can't do [__] no I'm
just like I must have like sent some
young Jewish children on a train or
something in my past life I mean why do
you have to go all right let's just say
SS Annie
I did something bad it's like hard to
not go there I'm like I'm being punished
it's like so weird maybe it's from the
Anne Frank email wait does your brother
have I did start after that does your
twin brother have them no my dad used to
have them in my aunt used to have them
yeah but they it went away for them
after a while yeah my dad said his were
just migraines but he did say class
drugs before so I'm like wait you kind
of though low-key like that your dad had
them too so you're like him yeah if it
was like my mom I'd be like
no it is I like every time I like my dad
you know I know me too like my dad and I
have such similar Health ailments which
is always I'm like well he is 80 but I
still I'm like oh no dad's so good for
their age by the way they're yeah
my dad's so scared of going like senile
and it's so funny I'm like you're you
already like he'll be like the Bruce
Willis thing will be like really like oh
my God I'm like Bruce was like 30 years
younger than me like you beat him dad
like you didn't get the thing he has
like you couldn't possibly have that I
feel like you guys are a different
couple when you're away from your home
yes better
Us in New York was a complete it was
like a completely new relationship it
was I felt like we were dating all over
again I was with New York Dave who I've
always wanted to meet because he lived
in New York before we met and so I was
like oh my God like he knows his way
around he's he was showing me around he
it it was completely different and
like way better do you have that are you
have you guys gone somewhere Todd goes
with me everywhere basically but he has
another job now so we're not doing
anything but also you guys aren't still
new it feels completely the same because
we bring Randy and stuff it's like it's
just like just bringing our house like
on the road but I'm also working it's
not like that much I know exactly what
you mean though because I I don't know
if I was just being I was just not ready
for a relationship
um during a period of my life so I kept
I always got into relationships with
boys that lived either in other
countries or in other cities like I
would always seek like long distance
Arrangements just so I would have and
usually with people that I couldn't see
myself like Going the Distance with
um but what I noticed is when I was in
their Hometown I was really attracted to
them because they were in control like I
could see them in their element I could
see you know the ease you know with the
way they moved when they would come stay
with me when they would stay with me
they weren't driving I would have you
know and they didn't know their way
around and I was I got like the ick
several times and I think that's so
unfair to them obviously but like I
couldn't help the way I used to do the
same thing it's uh expiration dating is
that what it's called yeah it's like you
know it's not gonna work out it's like
there's so many barriers in between it
and you can be like so in love with them
and they're like yes I was in yeah I was
in Germany I met this guy was like so in
love with him I was like oh my God we're
gonna be together and then when he came
to America I was like ew get away from
me loser yeah that exactly I've done
this several times I did it with a boy
from from London
um one in Spain and one in Australia and
each time that they would come over here
I would like lose my attraction and um
but I think that's exactly it's it's
what's what Annie is saying like it was
fun to like have this fantasy of being
like Oh I have this boy we're gonna have
these like mini romances like really
like intense vacations almost yeah it's
like a vacation boyfriend it's like
having like a guy a free local tour
guide yeah and the sex is always great
because you haven't seen each other and
you're not in your place so it's like
when then they come to your place it's
like you're like all right you're
interrupting my schedule it's so hard
when you first start dating someone to
figure out like how your schedules fit
together and stuff and what you're
willing to but it's like ugh I don't
want to be your [__] tour guide no
but legit this is so like the novelty of
showing up in New York after David been
there for a month like he had his whole
apartment situation like that novelty
was so hot like it was I almost feel
like I want to remember that because if
there's ever like a slow period you know
I'm saying like where I'm like we just
need to go somewhere and like I need to
you need to see the person in their
element or something like that and then
so when you're like Dave we have to move
to New York what does he say
it's okay interesting so
sometimes he would say things like
let's just go home and see
and then eventually he just stopped
responding and I was like I actually
called him out I was like I noticed that
sometimes when I say things you just
kind of like let them go and don't react
I was like well played he was like yeah
so he just kind of like let's go and but
he did say that he's like we cannot move
he's like we have a house in L.A like
we're not moving here but um and now
that I don't cry no
and my dad also thank you for laughing
my dad my dad was like she just answered
very seriously
my dad was like I was like Dad I'm so
obsessed with New York I have to live
here and he's like you're obsessed with
whatever the last place you were at is
and I'm like I need to take that into
consideration because
La is great you can spend so much time
in both places too it's not like
yeah you had a good setup though having
that place and everything yeah like him
having a job there was so ideal like I
don't know when that'll ever happen
again but I don't know you lived in New
York do you feel like any aspirations of
going back I when I get there love it I
have like such anxiety going back it's
like I blacked out the whole thing I
just it's like so weird wait what do you
mean like every time I it's like
when I'm I loved living in New York it
was so fun it was so awesome I never
thought I wouldn't live in New York then
when I moved to L.A like Miss New York
and move back one more time and then
when I moved back to LA I was like I
love LA and I love living here and then
didn't go back to New York as much and
then the longer of time I stay away from
it the more I get a lot of anxiety when
I think about going and what is the
anxiety about where am I going to stay
what am I going to do I have to bring
all my stuff about on my car to like
keep stuff in but do you think it'd be a
little bit different now now that you
know you're an established comic you
have the money to go back to New York
wouldn't that be like a completely
different experience yeah yeah it is and
then when I get there it's always like
oh this [__] City's like alive it's
electric I love it I like would like
walk down the street and hug the air you
know I loved it there okay that's
strange I bet you did a couple Twirls on
Broadway
sure if there was a puddle
um but yeah it's like a weird and I have
like a city Amnesia
I've been feeling that lately like I
don't know where I am anymore
speak on that we just go thank you guys
for listening
you guys don't feel like you're just
like
you're yeah he's just getting through
your days and you're just kind of not
like present that you're just doing what
you're supposed to be doing and that you
don't really kind of know where the [__]
you are who you are what time it is
exact opposite really no I actually feel
that way and that's why going to New
York was so like invigorating is because
I feel like life here becomes a little
bit like a blur at least for me and
that just like I don't know but you also
travel a lot so that should solve that
because I travel far because I go to the
opposite of that you're in like
different worlds a lot maybe you need to
establish like a routine this is gonna
sound
um not good for the long-term goals of
this podcast but I really have been
thinking non-stop about moving
permanently back to Asia what yeah I
cannot get it out of my head
make up [__]
no we'll go we'll go there and film and
you'll come here we'll do it this is
crazy thing I think we talked about it
with teffy it's like when I'm there like
I just feel like safe it just feels good
right and each time that I go there it's
it's my New York you know it's that
place where I'm like God I just I really
want to live here I grew up here I think
it's Memorial her parents basement oh
yeah no Hawaii is her my parents
basement we already have that
um you guys thank you so much for tuning
in and we will be back with a brand new
episode
see you then bye guys
[Music]